[Music]
listen we've talked about this before
you started as an actress but then for a
number of years you were a casting
director yes in Atlanta doing commercial
casting and you were in Atlanta doing
commercial casting and it leads to the
belief that when they were casting this
show you said I found someone terrific
and then you know I wasn't casting the
walk you weren't asking the walking down
yeah no I wasn't doing that
yeah so how did it all happen then well
I had done a project a brief project and
a film called the mist with Frank
Darabont who originated a series for
agency and three years after we shot
that I was I was in the casting office
and got a phone call that this project
was being made and there was a part and
I said well I'm available and I figured
I would be dead and you know a couple of
episodes right at the end of the week
right and um here we are four years
later and I've since been replaced at
that casting office Oh
the casting office replaced you okay and
you're gonna get next week's script
that's the scary part
danai I have to ask you I'm so used to
seeing you as we shown that when I first
walked into the dressing room and met
you for the first time
when I met you for the first time you
had this big happy smile and and it's so
different from your character is such a
it's such a shocking difference do you
think your characters gonna be smiling
some more on the show I don't know I
mean I think I have a lot more to smile
about you know and playing her actually
makes me smile more probably exactly
like wow I can go home turn on the
faucet and like hot water comes out and
you know this pooted my fridge and yeah
my car has gas and I know how to get
more gas you know so I I actually uh I
think she makes me smile more but I
don't know how much she has to smile
about no no it's a pretty grim situation
but you are fantastic with that sword
you were absolutely brilliant with that
sword how much are you working with the
sword constantly do you carry it with
you when you go to the supermarket I
mean what I don't but I do have a few in
my trunk and it's not really by you know
by any like design it's just that when I
go to rehearse or whatever sometimes I
have a couple in my trunk and I have had
you happen to have samurai swords in
your trunk that doesn't sound good to a
police officer I tried like my massive
purse you know where you put stuff so
like after I've done rehearse a guy I
put it in the trunk and I've have had
some guys who wash the car going uh
what's up with this what are these don't
like just leave that alone play with
that all you have to do is look at them
the way you look at everybody on the
walking dead and they're gonna because
you have the most intimidating sideways
stare I think I've seen in the medium
movies or yeah yes you do
she does ask me I get recognized
it depends some of the real hardcore
fans absolutely and the guys at the car
wash
no no those one he did not recognize so
they were they're a little confused they
just think you're really big big knives
yeah
you are not didn't eight tonight you are
not a fan of horror in general you
didn't grow up as a horror fan I did not
I was a massive scaredy cat I watched
like 20 minutes of American Werewolf in
London when I was very small and if I
was done I was done for life don't like
getting scared right well it wasn't
you've found the perfect job